.
ALWAYS GOOD TO BE ON WITH YOU.
>> Brian: ALSO TONIGHT PRESIDENT
TRUMP ANNOUNCING HIS RALLIES ARE
GOING TO BE UP AND RUNNING
AGAIN.
HE'S GOING TO CALL IT THE SAVE
AMERICA MOVEMENT, WHY NOT.
OBVIOUSLY IS HE STILL FEELING
THE POWER OF BEING 45.
>> SO I'M VERY HONORED TO SAY
THAT MY ENDORSEMENT MEANS MORE
THAN ANY ENDORSEMENT THAT HAS
EVER BEEN GIVEN BY ANYBODY.
>> Brian: SO MY NEXT GUEST IS
ONE OF THE FIRST TO STAND BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN 2015 AND-16
BY HIS SIDE THROUGH HIS
PRESIDENCY AND IS WORKING HARD
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS TO
RAISE MONEY FOR REPUBLICANS IN
HOUSE AND SENATE SEATS.
AND MAYBE I IN THE WHITE HOUSE
IN 2024 HIMSELF.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE SHOW
FORMER NEW JERSEY GOVERNOR
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
AND ON THE BOARD OF THE NEW YORK
METS WHO HAPPEN TO BE IN FIRST
PLACE COINCIDENCE WELCOME BACK
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE.
>> GOOD TO BE BACK.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Brian: YOU SAY THE CONFIDENCE
IS UP.
WOULD YOU SAY HE HAS SHOWN THE
POWER IN PRIMARIES SO FAR WITH
HIS ENDORSEMENT?
HEAD OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND
GOING FORWARD IN THE 2022
MIDTERMS IN PARTICULAR DISTRICTS
HE WILL CONTINUE TO BE A BIG
FORCE, BRIAN, IN OTHER DISTRICTS
LESS SO GIVEN THAT HE IS NO
LONGER PRESIDENT.
BUT, CERTAINLY, YOU KNOW, I
THINK EVERYBODY SHOULD WANT
EVERY REPUBLICAN INVOLVED IN A
POSITIVE FORWARD-LOOKING WAY TO
MAKE TWO CASES.
WHY OUR IDEAS ARE BETTER THAN
THE DEMOCRATS AND WHY WHAT JOE
BIDEN AND THE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS IS DOING RIGHT NOW IS
SO DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Brian: GOVERNOR, I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HEARD HIM WITH SEAN
HANNITY LAST NIGHT.
ONE OF THE FIRST TIME I HAVE
SEEN HIM INTERVIEWED WHERE HE
DIDN'T BRINGS UP THE 2020
ELECTION MUCH.
HE SAID BASICALLY I LOST THAT
ELECTION.
I MIGHT BE RUNNING FOR ANOTHER
A GOOD SIGN, I THINK, FOR
REPUBLICANS, YOU?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, WHAT I HAVE SAID ALL ALONG
IS LOSING PARTIES LOOK IN THE
REAR VIEW MIRROR.
WINNING PARTIES LOOK IN THE
WINDSHIELD TOWARD THE FUTURE AND
MAKE A CASE WHY THEIR IDEAS ARE
BETTER THAN THE FOLKS WHO ARE IN
POWER RIGHT NOW.
AND TO BE THE EXTENT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECIDES TO GET
ON BOARD WITH THAT AND START
TALKING ABOUT THAT, RATHER THAN
TALKING ABOUT THE PAST, THAT'S
NOTHING BUT GOOD FOR OUR PARTY
AND FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Brian: PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME
BACK AND SIGNED A PIECE INTO
LEGISLATION.
WE HAVE ANOTHER HOLIDAY
JUNETEENTH CELEBRATING THE MARK
WHEN TEXAS FINALLY GOT WORD AND
CONFIRMED THAT SLAVERY WAS OVER.
IS THIS A GOOD THING FOR THE
COUNTRY?
>> I THINK IT'S FINE, BRIAN.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T REALLY HAVE
ANY PROBLEM WITH IT GIVEN
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT JOE BIDEN
IS UP TO, THIS GOES VERY LOW ON
THE LIST OF THINGS THAT I CAN
OBJECT TO.
I AM MUCH MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
$6 TRILLION IN PROPOSED
SPENDING.
HUGE TAX INCREASES.
WEAKNESS TOWARDS CHINA.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT I'M
MUCH MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THAN
WHAT HOLIDAY HE PUTS INTO
EFFECT.
>> Brian: JUST SO MUCH IS
CHANGING IN OUR COUNTRY, EVEN IN
YOUR STATE OF NEW JERSEY.
IN NEW JERSEY, THIS RANDOLPH
BOARD OF EDUCATION HAS DECIDED
TO REMOVE ALL HOLIDAYS FROM THE
CALENDAR.
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO SAY OFF
DAYS.
YOU KNOW RANDOLPH.
THAT USED TO BE UNDER YOUR
AUSPICES.
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
>> IT'S INSANE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THIS ALL STARTED BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO RENAME COLUMBUS DAY
INDIGENOUS PERSONS DAY.
AND PEOPLE IN THEIR TOWN
OBJECTED TO THAT.
SO WHAT DID THEY DO?
NOT KEEP IT COLUMBUS DAY.
TAKE THE NAMES OFF EVERY
HOLIDAY, MEMORIAL DAY, VETERANS
DAY, LABOR DAY.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ABSURD, BRIAN.
BUT HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS.
I TWEETED OUT OPPOSITION TO IT,
LOTS OF PEOPLE IN NEW JERSEY
HAVE BEEN DOING THE SAME.
SO I NOW UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
HAVE SCHEDULED AN EMERGENCY
MEETING FOR MONDAY NIGHT TO TAKE
A VOTE TO RESCIND THIS STUPID
POLICY.
I SENT OUT A TWEET THE OTHER DAY
SAYING EITHER THEY NEED TO
RESCIND THE POLICY OR THEY ALL
NEED TO RESIGN.
HOLIDAYS MEAN SOMETHING.
AND WE -- MEMORIAL DAY IS NAMED
SO THAT WE DO REMEMBER, NOT TO
FORGET.
BUT THIS IS WHAT IS GOING ON IN
OUR WOKE SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
AND ALL OF US NEED TO STAND UP
AND SPEAK OUT AGAINST THIS
STUFF.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY AWFUL FOR
OUR KIDS.
>> Brian: I JUST LOOKED AT THESE
STATS BEFORE I HOPPED UP HERE
TODAY.
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE 18 AND UP IN
AMERICA.
55% HAVE GOT AN VACCINE.
KNOW HE THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT.
NEITHER ONE OF US ARE DOCTORS.
YOU GOT IT YOU ALSO GOT THE
VIRUS.
WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE TO OTHER
AMERICANS?
>> MY MESSAGE TO THE OTHER
AMERICANS IS TWO FOLD, FIRST
OFF, HAVING GOT THEN DISEASE,
IT'S VERY RANDOM IN TERMS OF HOW
HARD IT HITS YOU.
AND ONCE YOU GET IT, IT'S VERY
HARD TO DEAL WITH FROM A
TREATMENT PERSPECTIVE.
SO YOU DON'T WANT TO GET
COVID-19.
SECONDLY, I SAY TAKING THE
VACCINE IS LIKE PUTTING A SEAT
BELT ON WHEN YOU GET IN THE CAR
IT DOESN'T GUARANTEE YOU, BRIAN,
THAT IF YOU GET IN AN ACCIDENT
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BE HURT OR
KILLED BUT IT MAKES IT MUCH,
MUCH LESS LIKELY.
IN ADDITION, IT MAKES IT MUCH,
MUCH LESS LIKELY THAT YOU COULD
GIVE COVID TO ANYBODY ELSE.
I THINK GIVEN THOSE THINGS AND
THE SAFETY OF THE VACCINE HAS
SHOWN, I WOULD HOPE MORE AND
MORE AMERICANS TAKE THE VACCINE
BECAUSE THEN IT COULD BE GOOD
FOR THEM AND GOOD FOR THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
IN THE END, IT'S EVERYBODY'S
CHOICE.
EVERYBODY GETS TO MAKE THEIR OWN
CHOICE REGARDING THEIR HEALTH,
BUT I BELIEVE IT'S THE RIGHT
CHOICE TO MAKE GIVEN EVERYTHING
I HAVE READ AND SEEN.
>> Brian: IF YOU FOLLOW ANY
PLAYOFF HOCKEY, PLAYOFF
BASKETBALL METH YOU SEE PEOPLE
IN THE STANDS IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE VACCINE THERE WOULD NOT BE
WHICH IS ALL GOOD NEWS FOR YOU
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE GOVERNOR
CHRISTIE GETS ON THE BOARD AND
THE METS ARE IN FIRST PLACE BY I
THINK FOUR GAMES.
I'M NOT SURE IF THAT'S A
COINCIDENCE OR NOT.
I'M PUTTING MY BEST PERSON ON
TOP OF THIS STORY AND WE WILL
SEE WHAT WE COME UP WITH.
GOVERNOR, THANKS FOR JOINING ME.
>> THANKS, BRIAN, YOU KNOW
LEADERSHIP MATTERS, BABY.
LEADERSHIP MATTERS.
>> Brian: YOU ARE LEADING THAT
TEAM YOU AND JACOB DEGRUM.
>> I WILL DEFER TO JAKE, BRIAN.
>> Brian: EVERYONE EXCEPT FOR
MAYBE CY